[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor hi listening friends would you
like to hear an amazing fact
in July 2018 an Indonesian teenager
adelai adeling was minding his floating
fishing Hut when he awoke to find
himself drifting alone far out in the
ocean
during the windy night the Rope of his
wrong pong snapped a rompong is a little
Hut about six feet by six feet on a
floating raft with no motor paddles or
steering during the first few days
drifting at Sea he survived on his
meager food and water supply but then he
turned to eating raw fish and drank
salty seawater he filtered through his
clothing in the 49 days he was adrift up
to 10 ships passed by but none of their
Crews noticed him
alone at Sea he sang Christian songs
read the Bible he carried and earnestly
prayed that he would live to see his
parents again he admits that at one
point he felt so depressed he considered
drowning himself but he kept going
through prayer
his mother told the news agency AFP how
she learned of her son's disappearance
his boss told my husband that he went
missing so we just surrendered to God
and kept praying hard
on the 31st of August he spotted a
Panamanian coal ship that recognized his
signals of distress
Mr adelang was unaware that he had
floated all the way from Indonesia 1200
miles to the Waters of Guam in the
Pacific
the crew of the rescuing vessel gave him
water food and a change of clothes and
Mr Adeline stayed with the ship for a
week until he reached its destination in
Japan two days later his prayer was
answered and he was reunited with his
family in Indonesia
you know Pastor Cruise that's just an
amazing Story of Survival and 18 years
old and he was able to do that and the
loneliness can you imagine 59 days and
it it reminds me of that verse he spent
the time praying and he providentially
he was a Christian a lot of Indonesians
are Muslims but he happened to be a
Christian and that promise in the Bible
called upon me in the day of trouble and
I will deliver you and you will glorify
me that's by the way Psalm 50 verse 15.
reminds us that uh God answers prayer
yes he does God God delivers us when we
call out to him
um
in our prayers and our everyday lives
but also there's an ultimate Deliverance
that's coming and that Deliverance is at
the second coming right where God's
coming on something even bigger than a
ship he's coming with the Clouds Of
Heaven with all of the angels to deliver
all of those who call out to him for
deliverance and on that if you want to
learn more about God's ultimate
deliverance we have a study guide for
you so if you want to call in and get
this free offer on Ultimate Deliverance
a study guide you can call
1-800-835-6747 or if you want if you
have a phone you can just dial pound 250
and say the keyword Bible answers live
and ask for the ultimate Deliverance
study guide amen well as you've noticed
Pastor Ross is off tonight Pastor Aaron
Cruz who is one of our Associates at the
Granite Bay Hilltop church is joining us
tonight and Aaron's been here two or
three times so far this will be my third
time amen back and so we're going to
begin with a word of prayer all right
let's pray together
dear heavenly father Lord we're so
thankful that you are our deliverer Lord
you you saved us on the cross of Calvary
you offer your salvation freely to all
and we're looking forward to that
ultimate Deliverance uh when you come
through the Clouds Of Glory now Lord as
we spend some time uh Fielding some
questions about the Bible about you Lord
please give us Direction and wisdom as
we direct people to your truth in your
word we pray in Jesus name amen amen
well let's see who do we have lined up
Pastor Cruz all right our first caller
for today her name is Debbie so Debbie
is calling in from Canada hello Debbie
welcome to Bible answers live are you
there hi pastors how are you doing doing
great thanks for calling
this week Pastor Doug and we were
talking about organ donation
and I have the second question to that
is what's your
um theory on or the Bible Zuri on
cremation
okay good question we get that question
from time to time and I'll just mention
quickly Debbie I'm assuming you can get
on YouTube
uh I did a YouTube this last year
because we we had that question several
times on uh is cremation biblical and
I'll have a lot more information there
than I can share briefly here but I will
tell you just in a nutshell that
typically in the Bible the Bible example
for burial is burial I should say the
way that they dealt with the the dead
that's not to say a person who's been
cremated can't be resurrected or that
it's classified as a sin anywhere
but the the typical example it says you
know Abraham Isaac Jacob Joseph it talks
about about them being buried Moses God
buried Moses
um and then you know in the resurrection
talks about those sleeping in their
graves
but you do have examples in the Bible of
people like Jonathan who we expect to
see in the kingdom and he was uh after
he was killed by the Philistines his
body was recovered and cremated by the
men of jabeth Gilead so you've got at
least a couple of examples in the Bible
the people that were burned but they're
certainly going to be saved so that's
that's what the bible really teaches
about it and the reason that most of the
the early Christians and the protests
Catholics both they saw that the pagans
were cremating they thought that man is
made in the image of God and even in
death because man reflected the image of
God that should be treated sacredly so
they chose burial okay thank you very
much thank you so much for calling
Debbie
all right well uh we have one Debbie
that called in and believe it or not our
second caller is another Debbie but this
one is Debbie Smith calling in from
California and says here Debbie this is
your first time calling in welcome
Debbie are you there
yes hi I'm here
here hi Debbie what's your Bible
question
well I don't know if it's necessarily
like a Bible question but I kind of I
don't want to make like a drawn out
quite long drawn out question but I
wanted to know like what do you do when
you feel like you're lost and like your
faith is like not as strong and you
don't really understand the Bible like
you would want to as well as wanting a
relationship with God also
well I yeah I'd say first thing that's
wonderful if uh if you're feeling that
hunger that's uh that's a beautiful
thing
and um there's there's ways that a baby
grows you know once a person is born
they need to breathe they need to eat
and they need to rest
and uh you know that's also true with us
when we come to God if if we pray Debbie
and we say Lord I Want A New Beginning I
want you to come into my heart I'm tired
of my life of sin I'm I'm I feel bad
about my mistakes and we've all sinned
and you ask him to forgive you he
forgives you and gives you a new
beginning you repent of your sins
and then you begin to breathe that's
prayer
and you eat that's reading the word of
God as the bread of life
and then start sharing your faith you
exercise when a baby does those things
they're going to grow
so do you mind my asking Debbie have you
made a decision to invite the Lord into
your life and to get a new beginning
um I feel like I've tried but maybe I
haven't used the correct terms like how
you put it sounds completely different
from how I said it well you know the
Bible's pretty simple it uh it says that
first of all we have all sinned and the
penalty for sin is death uh sin is just
a selfishness and it it ends in death
Jesus died for our sins and he rose
again and he's alive today and he says
that shall send his holy spirit to be in
our hearts he gives us peace and
forgiveness and then we feed our
Christian experience and you grow in the
Lord by the reading praying and living
the life sharing your faith
um
would you like to do that now and get a
new beginning
yes because I I do I just feel like
sometimes I don't understand it or maybe
I try to read the Bible like it's a book
also and then it's like I'm sorry I know
it's a lot um another thing is like when
I ask God to forgive me I know he
forgives me but I don't forgive myself
it seems like well who's the more
important judge you or God
okay so if God forgives you then you
cannot put yourself at a higher Tribunal
his forgiveness is the most important so
you you need to forgive yourself because
if you're a new Creature if you're born
again then the old record is gone right
you're a different person
yes
so with a new birth hey Debbie could I
pray with you and then I'd like to
recommend that you sign up for the
amazing facts Bible study course it's
free let me hear a prayer with you and
then Pastor Cruz will tell you how to do
that okay is that okay yeah yeah
Father in Heaven I just pray you'll be
with Debbie and any out there like her
that are listening that want to get a
new beginning that they'll just come to
you accept your forgiveness that they
can be for uh forgiving themselves and
then just have that peace that comes
from a new life as they repent of their
sins and keep their eyes on Jesus so be
with her and bless and we thank you and
pray in Jesus name amen
amen and uh yeah Debbie if you want to
get a uh what you were asking is you
want to understand God better you want a
new beginning you want to study the
Bible and a great tool for understanding
the Bible are the amazing facts Bible
study guides and if you want to get
those you can call in right after you
get off the line with us call in
1-800-835-6747 and there uh you can ask
for hey get me some amazing facts Bible
study guides and they will hook you up
all right thanks so much who's next
Pastor Cruz all right our next caller is
Tom calling in from California hello Tom
are you there
yes I just want to say first of all
thank you again yeah pastors for all of
your hard work
you guys have been a true inspiration to
my wife and I oh praise God thanks so
much
and what's your question tonight well so
I understand that
and that as Christians you know
believing in Christ
um you know this through Christ that he
is our mediator to God
uh for our Salvation so my question is
um if the Jews did not believe in Christ
then or even now can they still be saved
yeah I think so
um because
you know there are some Jews that don't
know about Christ and they're not
accountable for what they don't know
um or it's been presented so poorly
that they don't know uh and they believe
in God now keep in mind
for the Jews who lived in the Old
Testament that are saved Abraham and all
of his posterity I guess the Jews really
begin with Israel in the tribe of Judah
but uh we know that you know millions of
them will be saved they believed in God
they believed in the savior they
believed in the Messiah they just did
not know it was Jesus
and some of them never saw the evidence
and God judges to whom much is given
much is required those who don't know
will be judged accordingly so yeah I'd
say of course there could be Jews saved
now there are some who uh have had the
truth presented to them and they
rejected and they've turned to believing
a lie deliberately and you know everyone
will be judged for that equally
yeah and Tom there's actually a a Bible
verse that directly answers that
question and it's found in Romans
chapter 11. uh here Paul is using an
illustration talking about the the Jews
as a uh an olive tree and the Gentiles
that are a wild Olive Tree and they are
grafted into the original Olive Tree now
check this out in Romans 11 verse 24 it
reads for if you were cut out of the
Olive Tree which is Wild by nature and
we're grafted contrary to Nature into a
cultivated Olive Tree how much more will
these speaking of Jews who are natural
branches be grafted into their own Olive
Tree so they the Jews gave us the Old
Testament right Genesis through Malachi
and they have many of the oracles and
the prophecies about the Messiah right
and so here Paul says hey if they accept
Jesus all who call on the name of the
Lord Romans chapter 10 verse 13 all who
call in the name of Lord will be saved
including Jews who accept Jesus as their
lord and savior thank you
good good answer hey I thank you for
that and you know just reminded me as
you were talking
um Paul ran into 12 Ephesian Believers
in Acts 19 that they were Believers in
God and uh but they hadn't heard about
Jesus yet so these were Jewish Ephesians
and he said he preached Jesus and they
got re-baptized but they had been
baptized they were living up to the
light and this is after Jesus is already
died and gone to heaven but they still
just didn't know so after it was
presented then that's a different story
okay who's next very good all right our
next caller is Anna calling in from
Oregon hello Anna
welcome to the show
hi good evening pastors good evening
so my question is from Revelation 10
verse 4.
okay and it pertains to when John heard
the seven Thunders
and then a voice from Heaven telling him
to seal it up and not write what he
heard
and I was wondering what what that means
and why why did the boys from Heaven
tell them to not write it and is there
anywhere else in the Bible that explains
anything about it
let me read that for our friends
listening and this is in Revelation 10
verse 4 and it says now when the seven
Thunders uttered their voice I was about
to write but I Heard a Voice from Heaven
saying to me seal up the things which
the seven Thunders uttered and do not
write them
now there is an example in the Gospel of
John and you may remember offhand where
God spoke from heaven
and some of the people understood
but some of the people you know God said
this is my beloved Son son said no it
was Thunder they didn't know what it was
and so it may be that John is referring
back to that experience and you are
using that analogy to say
there's something that people are not
going to understand
um also you've got in in the Book of
Daniel at the end of the book it said
seal up the book until the time of the
end at the end they'll understand so
he's this message is being sealed up now
anyone who says I know what it was they
got to be a little careful because even
John was told not to say what it was
yeah that's right yeah I I think the
best parallel would be in Daniel chapter
12 like you were bringing up in Daniel
12 right at the end of the book it says
seal up the book right and it because
it's not going to be understood until
the time of the end right and so there's
some things that there's a certain
timing right in which God is going to
reveal certain things to us throughout
human history and so we're not quite
exactly sure what those seven Thunders
are but um some have wondered is was it
the day or hour day and hour of the
coming or but it says no one will know
that so it's a mystery sorry you get
your money back Anna we're not sure well
Anna thanks so much for calling in all
right our next caller is calling in from
New York uh and his name is Anthony
Anthony welcome to Bible answers live
what's your question for us this evening
hello good evening pastors
um my question is based on
Philippians 2 verse 3. where it says let
nothing be done through Strife or
vainglory but in lowliness of Mind of
each esteem other better than themselves
and I'm sure that you know the context
has to do with like our relationship
with with others as Christians but I was
just wondering is there anything in
there that can help us with
understanding our the biblical principle
behind our career aspirations I mean
like people like Joseph and Daniel and
Moses they they had greatness thrust
upon them where they were elevated in
their positions but should we strive for
higher positions in our at our jobs and
our careers or is there anything wrong
with that is there a balance of you know
you know I heard somebody say Well when
you're in your performance review with
your manager it's not there's no time to
be modest you should kind of you know
not it's a lack of a better phrase boast
about how well you performed and right
why you deserve a pay raise so I'm just
wondering what is the balance
well first of all whatever you do as a
Christian you want to do it for the
glory of God uh our natural tendency you
know we all think about ourselves and we
all struggle with ego and pride
um but I I do think there's a balance
where uh you know it says whatever your
hand finds to do do it with all your
might uh God will put maybe a desire in
your heart to be successful in what you
attempt you read in Ecclesiastes
whatever your hand finds to do do it
with all your might and then in um Psalm
37 it says he'll give you the desires of
your heart
and so God May place a desire on your
heart to you know attain to a certain
Proficiency in something you might say
all right well I'm glad I'm a pilot but
I'd really want to be a commercial pilot
and is that wrong to want to have that
position and once you're a co-pilot you
might say I'd like to eventually be a
captain so that's just progressing and
being successful and efficient
I think that's normal and you can do
that in a humble way
so there's a balance and I think there's
another verse I'm trying to remember the
reference uh seek not greet things for
yourself
and maybe in Jeremiah but
um
so you know we shouldn't be doing it out
of Pride you're right David Joseph
Daniel
by putting God first he ended up putting
them in positions of leadership
yeah that's uh Jeremiah 45 verse 5
um that you were referring to about
secret things but yeah uh Anthony I
think the the key is to you know as
we're doing our best right whatever your
hand finds to do with all your might is
the key here I think that Paul's
addressing in Philippians is that you're
not pushing other people down in the
process exactly right as you're pursuing
excellence in all that you're doing
you're lifting people up with you along
the way right and I think that's the the
key biblical principle behind that
uh Anthony hope that was a satisfactory
biblical answer and thanks so much for
calling uh next caller is James calling
in from uh our very own state California
hello James welcome to the program
hello thank you my question concerns
revelation 22 11. speaking about the
close probation is there a connecting
text that tells us when probation will
close
yeah I think that the best connecting
text is if you look in Daniel chapter 12
verse 1 it says at that time Michael
will stand up the great Prince that
stands for the children of your people
and there will be a time of trouble such
as there never has been since there was
a nation even at the same time and at
that time thy people will be delivered
when Michael stands up usually when a
judge stands up that means he's done
listening to evidence
and cases are closed and when Christ
ceases to intercede for people just
before the end of time they'll be uh
life may go on for a little while but
the doomed are doomed a parallel would
be in the days of Noah
when Noah and his family and all the
animals got on the ark and the door was
shut
life went on for seven more days but
those that were on the outside were
outside those on the inside were inside
the unjust were unjust still
the righteous were righteous still so
there'll be a period of time just like
before the flood comes before Jesus
comes when probation is going to be
closed we don't know exactly when that
is but I think it's just before the
seven last plagues which means it hasn't
happened yet yeah we definitely don't
know uh from scripture the exact point
in time but definitely the seven last
plagues if you look at Revelation 16
verse 9 and verse 11 it explicitly says
that that the wicked who the plagues are
being poured out upon them it says they
did not repent and give him glory right
they did not repent of their deeds right
so here is let the the wicked continue
to be Wicked right so it's at the point
just before the pouring out of the seven
last plagues yeah good point good verse
all right James thanks so much for
calling
um our next caller again calling in from
California we have Deborah who is a
first-time caller Deborah welcome to the
show how's it going hi
supposed to try the name everything that
I've ever done bad in my life and as
forgiveness or do I just ask one time
can you please forgive me off for all my
sins oh great that's a great great
question well first of all can you
remember everything bad you've ever done
pretty close
okay you got a great memory I can't
so really bad stuff yeah well uh I I
mean you know we probably remember some
of the high points what I recommend is
that and you're really talking not just
about repentance you're talking about
confession
and both are important the Bible says if
we confess our sins he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and cleanse
us from all unrighteousness and that's
first John chapter uh one verse 9.
so uh being sorry repentance is being
sorry for your sins and willing to turn
away
what I recommend people do is you don't
have to remember every sin but you can
remember the categories start with the
Ten Commandments and say have I ever
been dishonest or lied say Lord forgive
me for lying have I ever had impure
thoughts forgive me for breaking the
seventh commandment have I ever taken
anything that didn't belong to me or
stolen and forgive me for that and go
through the Ten Commandments spread your
you know spread a little notepad on your
bad kneel and say Lord I'm guilty
Breaking Your Law I am sorry forgive me
help me to walk and follow Jesus now and
he promises to forgive you now if
there's something specific you think
well the Holy Spirit May convict me
about a particular sin King David prayed
Lord search me and try me see if there
be any wicked way in me Lead Me in the
way Everlasting the holy spirit will
show that to you if you just say Lord if
I'm forgetting something God's not
trying to trick you and say aha you
forgot something I can't let you into
heaven no if you say Lord I'm willing to
repent of whatever you reveal to me
he'll show you and then repent of that
and it's not like you're you know
revealing to God a big surprise that's
going to shock him he already knows
but by repenting and confessing we're
doing something we're asking God to help
us get victory in those areas we're
admitting that those things are sins and
it makes it easier for us to acknowledge
it and turn away
so I hope that helps a little bit Debbie
and I trust that uh you'll experience
that Peace and Freedom that comes when
we do repent and confess humble yourself
James says in the under the hand of God
and he will lift you up that's James
chapter four amen all right Deborah
thanks so much for calling we have time
for one more maybe before our break yeah
one more caller uh before I break we
have Gary calling in from Illinois
um Gary hi are you there with us
yes
revelation
hail storms or size of baseball hail
comes down through windshields and it's
all over the place so Illinois Germany
France Georgia and all over the world
but now the last plague in the Bible is
one of hail and it's a tithe of a talent
65 pounds is there any event a single
single event that causes a goal from
baseball size hail which is you know
very dramatic to me to uh 65 pound hail
yeah well just before Jesus comes it
tells us that there's going to be
um a catastrophic hail storm of course
nothing can really survive concrete
buildings can't survive a hail storm
with blocks of ice that way like you say
between 60 and 75 pounds
uh this is just helping us recognize in
the same way God destroyed Egypt during
the plagues when they would not let the
Israelites go the Lord is going to
destroy the world for persecuting his
people in the last days the wicked it
hasn't happened yet but uh stay tuned I
think we're living in the last days hey
listening friends we're going to take a
break just in a moment here and we have
the best half of the program that's not
a prophecy we're just hoping that we get
all warmed up we'll get more questions
in the second half you can text your
friends right now and say hey Bible
answers live is on tune in and they can
join us we're going to take a brief
break we'll be back with more Bible
questions in just a couple of moments
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
in six days God created the heavens and
the Earth
for thousands of years man has worshiped
God on the seventh day of the week now
each week millions of people worship on
the first day what happened why did God
create a day of rest does it really
matter what day we worship who is behind
this great shift discover the truth
behind God's law and how it was changed
visit Sabbath truth.com
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor this
morning my wife Karen sent me on a
mission she said when you're taping your
announcements this morning tell people
about my favorite amazing facts app it's
called The Amazing Facts radio app you
simply type that in amazing facts radio
you can download the app and you can
listen to good Christian music Bible
reading sermons all day long keep your
faith focused in heaven through the day
check it out if you haven't done it yet
the amazing facts radio app you'll be
blessed
thank you
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and this is a live
International interactive Bible study
we've been doing this for about 26 years
and it's just a joy to meet so many
people not only now on the radio but
we're on television and you can be
watching on the Amazing Facts YouTube
channel the Doug Batchelor YouTube
channel
and amazing facts TV and
you can tune into the radio if you're
living in California at kwol so
greetings to all those who are tuning in
and also those who are joining us and
tuning in at pray.com our show is hosted
there as well so welcome all of you yeah
thank you you hear a new voice this is
Pastor Aaron Cruz he's the grandson of
the founder of amazing facts Joe Cruz
and he's covering for pastor Ross
tonight so who's lined up next Pastor
Aaron yeah uh our our next caller here
is Marvin calling in from Tennessee
that's where I went to college in
Tennessee so Marvin welcome to the show
looks like you're a first time caller
welcome
well thank you for taking my call yeah
my question is on Luke in Luke 20
actually from 34 through 36. okay where
Jesus explains
to the Sadducees that try to trip him up
because all these brothers were marrying
the one brother's wife right
and he says that we're
as Angels does that mean
that we won't be as families in heaven
great question yeah the the Sadducees
didn't believe in a resurrection and so
they created a scenario they said well
what if one woman is married to seven
men over the course of her life and when
they go to heaven who's she going to be
married to and Jesus said and I'll read
this here from Luke chapter 20 verse 34.
he answered and said to them the sons of
this age marry and are given marriage
but those who are continued counted
worthy to attain that age and the
resurrection from the dead neither marry
nor are given in marriage nor can they
die anymore for they are equal to the
angels and are sons of God being sons of
the Resurrection
and so Jesus is basically saying you
know he told Adam and Eve to go be
fruitful and multiply they do not marry
in the sense that we do hear and
procreate because God told Adam and he
filled the earth the earth is going to
be filled now it'll be populated with
the redeemed but that doesn't mean if a
couple that's had you know one man one
woman get to heaven they're going to get
divorce papers when they get there they
can still be together in their children
and the ones that God has given them
natural love for and be a loving family
so it's not saying that families will no
longer have that special love it's
saying there's no more marriage as we
know it now where we're procreating
so some people think oh man you mean
there's no sex in heaven and I say well
look if that's worrying you I promise
you get there and you will be happy amen
don't worry about it
yeah it's a good question Marvin thanks
so much for calling uh looking for your
looking forward to your next time you
call in
our next caller is abdiel calling in
from Florida hello abdiel are you here
with us
yes good evening that was a
wonderful question from the last caller
thank you I was just thinking about that
yeah that's good good evening good
evening Pastor Doug Pastor Cruz uh this
weekend actually marks one year since
getting baptized and one thing that I've
learned is that following Jesus albeit
the most beautiful thing not easy so I
commend you both for your ministry all
these years and thank you because it's
helped quite a bit
and your question tonight so my question
is regarding Job 1 6. uh it would
probably sound better if you read it
okay uh Job 1 6. now there was a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and Satan
also came among them
okay you want me to stop there yeah so
so I have been reading a book very very
interesting and insightful lady author
things called early writings and it
talks about a tree of life Simba's
beings even Enoch is mentioned so I
guess my question would be are these
other beings or sons of God human are
they angels are they a species we can't
really imagine and I guess I almost feel
guilty for asking but if they are humans
would that make us a bit less unique I
was just curious to know
uh yeah I think that the Lord yeah look
at all the diversity of life we have on
our planet I'm talking about the animal
life
I mean I like watching nature programs
and it's just amazing to me how many
different kinds I just saw an amazing
fact this week that they they went the
deepest they've ever gone with cameras
and uh you know like 30 000 feet or
something they found fish swimming
around and they don't know how they
survived down there so you know from the
Eagles that soar above the Andes to the
bottom of the ocean God's got so many
different types of Life why would we
doubt that there are other forms of life
before I came over to the program
tonight that I was watching a report on
the James Webb Telescope and the
information that's coming in and they're
saying it's really destroyed all of
their theories about the age of the
universe because
they said it's much bigger than we had
ever dreamed and um
I believe God has unfallen sinless
worlds out there and other creations you
have several references in the Bible
where it talks about God in Hebrews I
think chapter two it says through whom
Jesus he made the worlds yeah and you've
got uh all the creatures in heaven it
talks about in Revelation praising him
so I think God has got a universe filled
with life just because and I don't think
UFOs are visiting the Earth
you know I think the only people
involved in what's happening here on
Earth are God the Father Son and Holy
Spirit and Angels it's like the hospital
staff because we've got a contagious
disease once that is dealt with we'll be
able to interact with the unfallen
worlds so I appreciate that abdiel
hopefully that helps a little bit by the
way I've got a sermon you can listen to
online and it's called is there life on
other worlds and it's a YouTube Sermon
you'll just find
yeah again thanks abdiel for calling in
our next caller is junith calling in
from Nevada our neighboring state here
hello Judith welcome to the program
what's your question for us this evening
hello uh
dog and Buster Aaron can you hear me
well yes yes we can
yes okay in the context of Revelation 21
8 one of those who will be thrown in the
lake fire of hell are the astrologers
now what is the relation of astrology to
Babylonia because this has been
bothering me is it the Earthen vessels
otherwise or the angels that were
received by the Dragon Tales you see the
manipulated
or yeah is this the but embodiment of
the snake and the the Satan as the the
head
yeah oh sorry I think we got cut off
yeah but I think we got the gist of your
questions Eunice
um when it talks in Revelation about
those that are cast into the Lake of
Fire it mentions uh people who are
astrologers and now astrologers are
different than uh astronomers and I was
just talking about astronomy nothing
wrong with the legitimate study of the
heavens
and the heavenly bodies and that's how
we get our calendar astrology and the
Zodiac does date back I think even long
before ancient Babylon and while they
kind of divided up the stars in the
heavens with these different
um uh constellations you know we can
look up and we can see cassiopeida and
we can see Orion in the sky they saw
those as gods and that they had an
influence on our Earth and that people
born under different signs they were
given to certain traits and there's
nothing in the Bible that's that's like
Hocus Pocus Witchcraft and the Bible
forbids witchcraft so there's nothing
wrong with astronomy but astrology when
people are Consulting the lucky stars to
find out their future is total nonsense
and I'll just give you a personal
testimony
I grew up my mother and all of her
friends were into astrology and as soon
as you met somebody they'd say what's
your sign
and they'd say oh I'm a Pisces I'm an
Aquarius or whatever oh yeah we should
get along it was and then my mother even
she began to write horoscopes and she
wrote horoscope songs she was a
songwriter and she and her friends that
did it they said we're just making this
stuff up and the papers are paying them
to write these things and they said oh
we don't even believe it ourselves hmm
so it's it's a the whole thing's a big
hoax and don't have anything to do with
astrology
yeah all right Judith thanks for calling
in our next caller is Lee calling in
from Texas hello Lee
how you doing hello pastors can you help
me yes you can
okay wonderful my my question is
um and I've been wondering about this
for quite some time
when the dragon makes war against the
Saints in the Book of Revelation should
the Saints fight back uh-huh okay good
that's a good question if it's a war I
say absolutely we should fight back
um if it's a war if you don't want to be
defeated you got to fight back the
question is how does the devil make war
is he making war with Bazookas and hand
grenades or is he making war with
deception and in that same chapter it
talks about the serpent that deceives
the whole world and so our battle our
weapon is and you can read about this in
Ephesians chapter six it says take up
the sword of the spirit which is the
word of God and so we fight error with
truth and the word of God hiding it in
our heart how did Jesus fight the devil
when he was tempted
he said it is written it is written it
is written and he quoted from the word
of God so Thy word I have hidden in my
heart that I might not sin against thee
store up the word of God in your mind
and that is the best way to fight the
devil in the last days yeah and in fact
right there in Revelation 12 it even
tells us right in Revelation 12 verse 11
just a few verses earlier it says and
they overcame him that is Satan by the
blood of the Lamb that's Jesus and his
sacrifice for us and by the word of
their testimony sharing what Jesus has
done through them
um so that would be the key and then
also going back to what you reference in
Ephesians chapter six it's it's
important to note in Ephesians 6 verse
12 the highlight verse here is we
wrestle not against flesh and blood
right so this is not a physical fighting
against Satan right but principality is
power it's a spiritual warfare as Pastor
Doug highlighted and we need to be
equipped with scripture to fight back
against the devil absolutely and you
know I think what would be a perfect uh
study for you Lee is we've got a book
and it sounded like you might be driving
so if you can just remember the armor of
God and when you get where you can make
a phone call then call in and and ask
for that free offer called the armor of
God yeah and you can call in uh an easy
shortcut way is just dial pound two five
zero and the key word is Bible answers
live and there you can ask for this
resource
all right thanks again Lee for calling
our next caller is Aaron which is my
name hello Aaron calling in from New
York uh are you there
hello Pastor Aaron hello Aaron that's
fun what's your question for us
my question is meant for Pastor Chuck
okay last week someone had asked whether
or not
that's all kosher and I remember Pastor
Doug saying that they are not because
they are related to swans and the bible
say that swans are unclean yes
well I searched the internet and saw
that several websites say that ducks are
Kosher
do you think the Jews think that's a
kosher because they are not explicitly
forbidden in the in the end of scripture
yeah no I know I was aware that uh many
Jewish communities say that they argue
about ducks and some say Dr kosher and
some say they're not uh I and there's
you know there's some areas where I
respectfully disagree with the Jews in
interpreting scripture
um I don't think for example in the
scripture when it says that you're not
to cut the corners of your beard
um it's not talking about growing the
long curly sideburns it says you're not
supposed to cut the corners of your
beard for the Dead
and so my Orthodox Jewish friends that
grow the long sideburns because they
think they're obeying adverse I think
they're misunderstanding their own
scripture when you know the Bible says
to write the word in your heart and in
your hand and on your head I don't think
he meant for us to hang phylacteries
with the word of God on our forehead he
meant the word of God is to be in your
mind and so I'd also disrespect with my
Jewish Brethren and again I'm Jewish at
least my mother was that when I read the
word and look at the definitions duck
does not fit into the category of the
clean foraging Birds the birds that are
clean are the quail these are birds that
go around in the woods and they pack in
the eat bugs and seeds and it's a quail
and the the Pheasant and the turkeys and
the chickens people will be happy to
hear chickens are clean but I would
never eat it and I went to a chicken
slaughterhouse when I was a kid I gave
up I gave up eating chicken long time
ago but anyway so I hope that helps yeah
I know that they're going to say some
are going to disagree but I think that
it fits uh King James version I think
says Swan and they're unclean Goose same
category Goose duck Swan yeah
all right Aaron well thanks for calling
in uh our next caller is Paul calling in
from Tennessee
hello Paul are you there
hey yes I'm here evening passes good
evening
um so I've got really I've got about a
million questions but given this day I
figured I'd go with one referring to
Jesus's resurrection uh this verse is
just really throwing me through a loop
okay so I'm in the First Peter Chapter 3
Verse 18 and 20. uh but specifically
verse 19 is is uh what I'm struggling
with it says in which also he went and
made proclamation to the spirits now in
prison who are the spirits imprisoning
what does this verse mean what what
version of the Bible are you reading
might I ask
um you know I've looked at it in a few
different this one is uh nasb 1995 I've
also checked in like ASV and ESV and the
nib okay yeah because you added a word
that is not in mine and let me just tell
you what it says and what I believe it
it means Paul is talking first of all
about the the spirit and you read in
verse 18 for Christ also suffered once
for sins the just for the unjust that he
might bring us to God being put to death
in the flesh but Made Alive by the
spirit now the subject now is no longer
Christ it's the Spirit by whom Christ
went and preached the spirit through the
Holy Spirit Jesus preached to the
spirits in prison is not talking about
ghosts in prison it's talking about
people who were spiritually imprisoned
back in the days of Noah says who are
formerly disobedient when Once the
Divine long-suffering waited in the days
of Noah while the ark was being prepared
in which few that his eight Souls were
saved through water there's a verse in
Genesis chapter 6 where God says my
spirit will not always strive with man
yet his days will be 120 years and so
God was saying back in the days of Noah
for 120 years God the spirit of Christ
Same Spirit that Rose Jesus from the
dead preached to those Wicked people in
prison those Spirits in prison
to save them and then he goes on he
talks about that you know they were
destroyed but Noah and his family
believed they were saved so it has
nothing to do with Jesus not really
dying on the cross but going into
another state and preaching to one group
of people that were getting a second
chance that would be totally out of
harmony with where the Bible says it's
appointed on demand once to die then the
Judgment you don't die and then get to
hear the gospel again
yeah great answer I just want to
highlight again in verse 19 when it says
by whom also he the he the antecedent
would be the spirit right the Holy
Spirit uh preached to the spirits in
prison right that would be take us right
back to Genesis 6 where the spirit right
was preaching through Noah to the
spirits in prison the spirits in prison
would just be the wicked people right
when you look over at Luke chapter 4 and
verse 18 this is Jesus quoting Isaiah of
what his mission was right and here he
says the spirit of the Lord is upon me
because he's anointed me to preach the
gospel to the poor he sent me to heal
the broken heart to Proclaim Liberty to
the captives right Spirits in prison the
spirits in prison those who are captive
by the sin of this world right so that
would be with that it's referring to so
hopefully Paul now did that make sense
yeah oh absolutely yes thank you very
much I I really needed an answer this
phone been on my mind all week so I know
I first read that and I struggled too
all right our next caller is Benjamin
calling in from California
uh Benjamin hello
Welcome to our program Hi how are you
doing Pastor doing well how are you I'm
doing well my question is in Revelation
16 12 I've been tripped up a little bit
with this I'm talking about the great
river Euphrates and I'm just curious I
know C represents people and usually
Earth represents baroness but what does
the great river Euphrates represent in
Revelation 16 12. well you know it says
in Revelation 17 it tells us the waters
which you saw are peoples and multitudes
tongues and Nations and so it's not just
sea water it would include river waters
now this is you know Revelation is
filled with symbols from the Old
Testament you need to know a story
Revelation talks I'm sorry I should say
the Bible talks about the fall of
Babylon in Revelation
and in the Book of Daniel
their little backstory that isn't uh
specifically spelled out is that when
Cyrus all the Jews knew this story but
when Cyrus wanted to conquer Babylon he
ultimately diverted the Euphrates River
so it no longer began to flow under the
walls of of Babylon
a contingent of soldiers from Cyrus
snuck under the walls they opened the
city Gates and let in the rest of the
Army and the inner gates had been left
open as well and so Babylon fell when
the Euphrates was dried up Babylon fell
referring to that time in history you
read in chapter 16 this verse in chapter
17 and 18 it talks about the fall of
Babylon spiritual Babylon
so you know this might be an example
where most of the early plagues are
literal there's going to be literal
blood and sores and fire this one may
actually have a dual meaning
principally I think it's saying that
when spiritual Babylon is falling it's
resources its people are gonna turn on
her
and it says that they ultimately do term
the Ten Kings turn on Babylon
but it's I just think it's an
interesting note right now that the
literal Euphrates of river is drying up
it's in the news quite a bit lately but
I wouldn't look for that as much as I
look at the spiritual application yeah
and um it's the historical account is
recorded on the Cyrus cylinder right
that's the archaeological Discovery but
actually there is a small little hint
Isaiah yeah of Cyrus drying other river
Euphrates and that's in Isaiah 44 and
verse 27 it's a prophecy written over a
hundred years before Isaiah before Cyrus
was ever born and he uses Cyrus's name
twice and it says here who says to the
Deep be dry and I will dry up your
Rivers God foretold the way in which
Cyrus would defeat the Babylonian city
right so the river Euphrates drying up
is a reference to the fall of Babylon
and in the very next chapter Revelation
16 you have Revelation 17 and what do
you see there it's the fall of Babylon
yeah right 17 and 18 the fall of Babylon
so it's definitely a symbolic
understanding which we have to compare
scripture with scripture and understand
the spiritual meaning I think even in
Isaiah 45 is it that it it says that the
gates would be left open yeah so the
whole thing is really there
well thank you and hopefully that helps
a little Benjamin uh pastor we got time
maybe for one more question let's see
what it is over a break here yeah all
right our our next caller here is Lisa
calling in from Georgia and she's a
first time caller so hey Lisa welcome to
the show what is your question for
tonight
Hi how are you doing great thank you
awesome my question is
um I've always wondered is it possible
that we that Humanity could be the
falling angels you know could we is it
possible that God has given us a second
chance to uh to get it right I don't
know you know because we're born into
sin and we just have a sinful nature and
you know we have to learn to to to do
right and to to you know be as God has
uh called us to be so I if it's just
something that has been in my you know
in my mind and heart to to ask this
question yeah well it's a valid question
I know there are some churches that
teach that prior to our Earthly human
existence that people existed as angels
and uh I think that there are even uh
stories of people that die I mean some
churches that teach that when you die
you become an angel when you go to
heaven
that famous movie called A Wonderful
Life where this angel named Clarence to
try to do good deeds so he can get his
wings and you know what the Bible
teaches and by the way you said in
Genesis I think you meant Revelation
when Satan and his angels are cast down
it's in Revelation 12. but um
the Bible is pretty clear that angels
are humans are created I think there's a
verse in Hebrews it says that he created
the Angels they are ministering spirits
of God this is God's Army it's his
attendance his staff and that man Psalms
tells us man was made a little lower
than the angels we are a totally
different order of creation people did
not used to be angels that are now
reincarnated they want to do any good
because he don't remember it what good
is it so we are Unique Individuals God
makes every snowflake different
so certainly he knows us we're unique
one of a kind once in eternity he makes
you you we are not reincarnated from
some other animal or even angels yeah I
think when we piece together all of the
many verses about the angels and about
humans it becomes pretty clear that we
are we are not the fallen angels we can
side with fallen angels are we can side
with the righteous Angels but we are a
distinct order of being you know and I
think I just as you're talking I
remembered you've got Gabriel
who he appears to Daniel in the Old
Testament and then you know what 600
years later he appears to marry he
hasn't aged he hasn't come down to earth
to become someone else he's you know he
lives an eternal life
and so uh yeah these and Fallen Angels
there are angels that are Fallen they
come to the Earth and they're demons
they're devils and the Very down here
tormenting people now we do have a study
guide we'll be happy at least to share a
free study guide with you that talks
about did God make a devil it talks
about the Angels good and bad and how do
we get that Pastor yeah if you want to
get that study guide you can call into
1-800-835-6747 or if you have a phone uh
cell phone particular you can just dial
pound 250 and say Bible answers live and
there you can ask for the Bible study
guide all right for our listening
friends we're not quite done we're
signing off for our satellite stations
we'll be back in just a moment with a
rapid fire Bible questions so don't go
away
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
hello all right we are back for a
two-minute questionnaire all right
Pastor Doug question number one is from
Wendy who emailed in from New Zealand
right so you'll be all over the globe
and email in and her question is is the
phrase age of accountability biblical
no well you don't find the phrase age of
accountability in the Bible and you do
not find an exact age that is given
there certainly is
an age of accountability in other words
you don't find the word bible in the
Bible you don't find the word Millennium
in the Bible but it's in the Bible the
teaching is there and you don't find the
word Trinity in the Bible but the
teaching is there
the idea that a child gets old enough to
understand the difference between right
and wrong that principle is in the Bible
I think it's you can't find Bible
support for giving an exact age
typically when they're old enough to
understand the claims of the Gospel the
difference between right and wrong and
to hear the call of God and they to
respond and to be responsible for a
decision they're reaching that age of
accountability God's very patient with
children and because he knows they're
growing he made us that way
yeah and we're always judged according
to light which we're given so the older
we get and the more mind power we have
the better we can make exactly good also
before we go to the next question I also
want to remind anyone you can email in a
question all right you just call you
email into
balquestions
amazingfacts.orgs and that's how you can
get your questions up here all right our
next question is from Cami and Kami asks
are there people who are alive right now
who are already sealed uh with the Seal
of God or will the actual ceiling happen
at the time right before the mark of the
beast I think she's referring to
Revelation seven right yeah now well to
just be accurate there are people
through history that have received the
Holy Spirit and you know Ephesians tells
us grieve not the Holy Spirit wherewith
you are sealed for the day of redemption
so we all need the Holy Spirit to seal
us and settle us in our faith but then
there's a special seal of God that is a
juxtaposed with the mark of the beast in
the Book of Revelation and that's a seal
that's found in the law of God in Isaiah
it says bind up the testimony seal my
law among God's people and in the middle
of God's law you find the word holy only
one time and that's in the fourth
Commandment go look that up friends and
read it Exodus 20. start with verse 8.
yeah okay next question is by Laurel and
they ask if forever only means Until the
End of the Age how then should we relate
that to spending forever with Jesus yeah
well there are places where forever
means until a person dies but I just say
you've got to read it in its context
exactly hey thank you listen need
friends it's been a joy to be studying
the word of God with you we'll do it
again next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]